voyage sans passeport
la Hollande pays plus bas que la mer ou
l'une après l'autre des lames immenses
m'ont-elles assemblement à la
sous-titres
la Hollande n'est jamais vaincu mais la
mère est tenace
et ce qui est fait est toujours à
refaire ainsi s'inscrit le destin de ce
pays où chaque tempête réduit à néant
toute digue tout barrage et ravages
hélas ville et villages aveuglé les
brèches travailler nuit et jour et
savoir que ce qui est fait même s'il est
bien fait ne peut être œuvre durable
voilà ce que tout hollandais peut
apprendre à sa naissance en quelque
sorte un diegest de la vie et une
échelle réduite
le travail ne peut se faire qu'un marée
basse route et voie ferrée doivent être
surélevés
l'eau est évacuée au moyen de pompes de
canalisation
c'est la fin du désastre enfin de celui
là
et vous allez voir ce qu'il reste
mais la mer n'est pas le seul ennemi on
pourrait dire que ça serait trop beau
les ruisseaux se prirent à rêver d'un
mariage d'amour avec la mère et l'épaule
d'air derrière les Dick furent
envahissent cette fois par de l'eau
douce responsable les plus de printemps
il n'en est pas moins vrai qu'il fallait
drainer les prêts
et pour se faire on se servit du moulin
à vent le moulin est encore chacun sait
le symbole de la Hollande
un nouveau problème surgissait où jeter
l'eau dans la mer cela semblait logique
oui mais la mère est plus haute que les
terres d'où il devint nécessaire de
creuser des canaux et dire que pendant
ce temps le négave meurt de soif non par
faute du courage de ses habitants mais
en raison d'une vague de sécheresse à
quoi pense le fowvoyeur des destins de
l'homme
toujours à droite les Hollandais en
construisant les canaux dotent leur pays
d'un réseau économique qui permet aux
denrées de circuler d'une ville à
l'autre
maintenant un autre problème prenait
naissance celui des ponts rassurez-vous
il a été résolu
et aujourd'hui la Hollande possède
toutes sortes et toutes catégories de
les éclusions étaient indispensables
mais il n'est pas toujours aisé possible
d'en construire une
alors ils ont choisi un moyen terme
et voilà comment ils se sont arrangés
tu ne façon comme une autre de traverser
une route
et c'est ainsi qu'en Hollande les petits
bateaux prennent des jambes
l'eau est devenue esclave de l'homme
la terre est conquise pousse à
et là où il n'y avait rien existe
maintenant des élevages prospère car si
l'eau est néfaste elle fait aussi vive
pâturage
= bétail bétail lait beurre fromage et
tout naturellement nous en arrivons au
fromage de Hollande que vous avez tous
vu que vous connaissez tous et que
probablement vous avez tous goûté
celui-ci est sur le marché Dagmar
il faut au passage puisque c'est la
coutume admirait le costume des porteurs
de fromage
hello une fois de plus servir à l'homme
et ici le fromage
les fleurs les fleurs de Hollande
tulipes Narcisse jacinthe qui chaque
année transforme les champs en autant de
carré de tapisserie précieuses
chaque maison a les siennes
tout le monde les aime
et personne ne s'en prie
les Hollandais sont les jardiniers du
monde
Amsterdam la Venise du Nord
au bord des arbres
au vieil et solide maison
témoins de sa prospérité au XVIIe siècle
en ce temps-là toutes les histoires
commencent comme ça et celles qui ont
existé aussi en ce temps-là Amsterdam
centre commercial universel envoyé ses
flottes marchandes jusqu'au confins du
monde connu New York le savez-vous
s'appelait au préalable New Amsterdam
la bicyclette est aussi inévitable en
Hollande que la mère les polders les
tulipes et le fromage
le mariage est de tradition partout
alors pourquoi pas là-bas
et là-bas ils y sont célébrés selon
toutes les traditions
tradition peu négligeable
le sport à l'île de Berck consiste en
ceci
en Argentine on fait de même il est
probable que les Hollandais en sont
responsables
et toujours et inlassablement la mer
mais voici une belle victoire et oui de
chaque côté il y a la mer
vous a proposé voyage sans passeport
cette émission a été réalisée avec le
concours de Caltex et le Solange péter
montage Pierre Michel Rey script
Nathalie de Muret sont Annick wedi
illustration sonore Denise Glaser